[Music]
what do all these things have in common
yes they're all white they're all made
by apple but there's one more thing
they're all 19
but this is nothing new to apple in fact
the brand has a long history of pricing
not so sexy items right at nineteen
dollars there are currently several
products listed for nineteen dollars on
apple's website apple is so loyal to
this pricing model that this simple
cloth
is nineteen
and yes that's quadruple what you could
get a cleaning cloth from at amazon or
at target walmart or other stores and
that's why it took the internet by storm
after apple slapped a 19 price tag on it
no don't start with the macbooks no the
biggest part of this announcement was
the new microfiber polishing cloth that
apple put out for 19 dollars but why
what is it about a 19 price point that
19 number that gets apple so excited
let's dig in to start apple is making
use of something known as price charming
what is that
let's focus on the number nine
have you ever noticed that when you go
shopping you see all these items that
are priced at something 99
studies show that ending sales prices in
the number 9 generally makes people want
them more so you subconsciously decide
that those prices are justifiably
cheaper than ones ending in the number
zero and apple has completely bought
into the idea let's take a look
every single made by apple product on
its website ends with that special
number again literally every single
product from discharging cable to this
desktop to this apple watch
price strategist told me that's clearly
by design and the strategy is working
apple's category of 19 products grouped
in with its air airpods and smart
watches is starting to rival revenue
from mac sales
mac computers brought apple nine billion
dollars in a recent earnings report
whereas its wearables category including
the nineteen dollar due to ads brought
the company over 8 billion
the polishing cloth is apple's most back
ordered product and that means people
are more than willing to fork over 19
as long as there's an apple logo on it
which brings us to our next point the
pricing sweet spot
analysts i spoke to said that apple's
fascination with the number 19 shows
that the company believes 19 is neither
too high nor too low but just right to
woo prospective buyers
if apple were to sell products far below
20
it might make the brand appear cheap and
that would not align with the premium
market that apple wants to dominate
and the price point could also speak to
the type of customer that apple wants to
attract if they wanted everybody as
their customer i think that they would
be pricing different products slightly
lower that's gene munster a tech stock
analyst who has covered apple for over a
decade for example you might not buy
this adapter by itself but it's easy to
add on and toss it in the cart when
you're buying something more expensive
say i'm on the market for a new macbook
this one has apple's new m1 pro chip and
if i add it to my cart for say
1999 dollars what's another 19 on top of
that i might even add two 19 items for
good measure apple's products are
generally more expensive than your
average devices and they tend to attract
shoppers who are willing to pay more
especially since with apple consumers
seem to think they already know what
they're going to get what matters is
that they're getting something from a
brand that they trust
and ultimately apple has consumers that
are willing to
make that jump even though as a
percentage it's
certainly expensive but this concept of
i'm an apple user and i want to surround
myself with all apple products that have
that seal of approval when i reached out
for thoughts from apple a spokesman
declined to comment apple says it prices
its offerings to be competitive but
let's be clear there are cheaper
alternatives out there too
not every company charges nineteen
dollars for very simple products
in fact
most of these nineteen dollar items can
be found somewhere else for much cheaper
so here's apple's cloth the 19 rag that
someone let me borrow because i couldn't
get my hands on it myself as you can see
the wait time is at least 10 weeks
but now that i have it it's soft it
looks nice almost has a suede-like
texture and it even gets fingerprints
off my computer
i tried to find a similar one on amazon
so i read through some reviews and after
about two days i got these a pack of
three for about nine bucks
they work just fine
they look nice too and they got
fingerprints off my gadgets and i have a
couple to spare them in case i lose one
so what does this all mean for you a few
things one if you don't care about brand
loyalty or don't care about little apple
stickers with your purchase you can buy
just as good products from other
retailers that will work just fine on
your apple gadgets and next time you
want to purchase a 19 charging adapter
remember that apple used to include that
in the box with iphones at no additional
charge
analysts told me that going with
products from other brands particularly
those on the lower end might have you
wishing you had just paid the premium a
polishing cloth probably isn't that
thing though what do you make of apple's
pricing psychology have you noticed any
of it at all
comment below and let me know your
thoughts and if you want to watch more
apple related content check out this
video on their new privacy policy also
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on the latest gadgets and the industry
that's powering them